on va faire un c'est quoi la suite
chanteur ces particules regard des faits
la ville entière qui fait le show et
soudain elle décide de descendre de
scène que va-t-il se passer
regarde
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer elle va
s'approcher de djezzy à lui rouler une
galoche
elle va mettre une gifle à un enfant
turbulent ou un fan turbulent elle va se
coincer des cheveux dans un ventilateur
va s'apercevoir qu'il ya la photo de
bernard montiel sur sa clope va se
passer les cheveux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est une vraie pro imaginez jean-michel
merde si cela s'est terminé lui passe
devant un ventilateur il a pu que me
wilhem question attention justin bieber
regardez il fait une pause pendant son
concert que va t'il
[Musique]
alors c'est quoi la suite qu'il va
discrètement vomir sur scène est-ce
qu'il va partir en courant vers les
toilettes le micro ouvert
est-ce qu'il va lancer son slip sur une
personne du public ou est-ce qu'il va
tenter un moonwalk est tombé sur un
danseur le monde il va revenir à vouthon
sera discrètement miraoui il meurt pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et apparemment c'est après 7,7 cette
chanson qu'il a écrit la chanson moi je
voudrais vomir sur scène un grand tout
est conne il est sur scène il s'est
monté un fan que va-t-il se passer
regarder
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce qui va se passer va danser
un zouk love avec un fan il va [ __ ] à
poil sont fans il va jeter le fan dans
la foule où ils vont chanter à cannes ce
joli nez ce téléphone dans la foule
voilà faut pas faire ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être lui qui a jeté la femme
ne veut pas
alors et un instant on était au concert
d'une chanteuse star en russie on va
voir la vidéo et on va voir ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
c'est quoi la suite le shérif donc moi
je parle a dit là bas historique dans la
fosse et continue à chanter un
producteur va lui tomber dessus et va
perdre sa robe était né en string où
elle va chanter dans le club de michou
oui je faisais norme est quand même
normal et lambert à tous ceux qui sont
sing sing
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
un jeu
c'est cool
most y voilà madonna allait en plein
show des brit awards
ah oui c'est les brit awards c'est comme
les brit awards c'est à dire les
meilleurs champions de qui mangent de
plekhanov regardez il ya madonna qu'est
la célébrité alors que va-t-il se passer
elle va encore pêché un de ses danseurs
elle va enlever son masque qui rêvait
d'être mado la niçoise va marcher sur sa
cape et faire une énorme chute où elle
va perdre le hot sa tenue et laissait
apparaître sa poitrine la d1 je suis
alors dit parce que c'est ce qu'a fait
majeur à quatre aviateurs des villages
si vous vous dites quoi regarder
[Musique]
m
ça fait beaucoup
les bacs et les tensions des mauvais
réflexe quand même un pas ça c'est sûr
attendait quelqu'un qui est tombé il a
ici garage et là j'étais en réception et
harry styles des one direction ramasse
une chaussure regardez
que va-t-il se passer d'aruba mon père
est là m les mecs et un cadre arcs est
parti sur la tête de ma mère
on a déclenché lorsque les adore qu'il
avait envie d'aller aux toilettes 0 il
ya une urgence ou pas c'est quoi la
suite les débats qui a lâché sur
appartient à raymond il va deuxième
chaussure dans les coucougnettes il va
verser de l'alcool dedans et boire cul
sec où il va jeter la chaussure sur le
visage de son frère ad il est nerveux
dany l'aluminium fade et regarder
oui je suis là et je vous le contraire
ça peut être retrouvé